let's bring in our panel a lot to talk
about there Tom Rogan commentary writer
for the Washington Examiner Charles Lane
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and Charles hurt opinion editor for The
Washington Times all right rudy is one
of the newest members of the legal team
and he is out there talking yes he is
out there talking and you know I do
think it's important that you know a lot
of people are speculating about whether
he went too far whether he got over his
skis last night last night was Sean
Hannity but at the end of the day I
think he wanted to accomplish two things
and he did accomplish those two things
one is he wanted to go ahead and set the
marker that in fact Donald Trump himself
did pay the money that went to the the
for the NDA agreement and the second
thing was that he wanted to accomplish
was he wanted to put out there that the
president did it for personal reasons
not for for the campaign he kind of
stepped on that a little bit this
morning on Fox & Friends where it seemed
to sort of he seemed to walk that back a
little bit but he wanted to accomplish
those two things he did and because he
did that I think the president is in a
lot better
is it a stronger situation because of
that now than he was when there were
questions about who paid for well and
Chuck was this clean up to this issue of
potential campaign violations dealing
with the FEC if the president tackles
this way if where do Giuliani says he
did pay it this is how it worked is it
it does it put out that fire for the
Trump campaign I don't think so I think
that started a whole bunch of new fires
this is like antics that are going on
around what is actually a pretty serious
issue a couple of weeks ago I think was
about a month ago on Air Force one the
president flatly denied knowing anything
about this payment which created a
situation which there were two
alternatives one he was lying or to some
other benefactor he was in the thrall of
some benefactor who was paying hush
money to his alleged former mistress
well now we know he was lying so if
that's sort of the best-case scenario
for him that's not a good case the
campaign finance thing is only the
beginning of the trouble because there's
going to be a whole inquiry now by the
Southern District of New York's US
Attorney into this chain of payment that
was funneled through
his then lawyer Michael Cohen and
whether there was any fraud going on in
that in terms of what he represented to
the banks and so forth I don't think
anything's been cleaned up okay so Tom a
lot of this it seems would go back to a
timeline of when the President did know
when he did get involved with payments
they've been very careful in their
language it's possible that they've been
telling the truth but parsing the words
very carefully to this point whether the
American people feel like it's wrong or
that they feel like they've been lied to
by the president that's a different
question altogether about whether he did
something legally wrong right and but I
think that notion of the American people
is what we're going at here or at least
what the Trump administration is trying
to do through Giuliani I think they
sense
Mulla closing in in some way whether
that be through Cohen whether it be
through collusion whatever and so for
them the best thing to do is to fight
this fight in the political domain
rather than a legal domain they know as
much as the law is supposed to be blind
ultimately because this is the President
of the United States any special counsel
if the president can get out ahead of
this and push this into that public
atmosphere I think they think that
Robert Miller perhaps will be more
amenable to negotiating or to backing
off I'm not sure if that's a good gamble
but I think that's what they're trying
to do well into this PR point a lot of
back and forth between Rudy Giuliani and
former FBI director James Comey of
course fired by the president today
about whether people are acting like
stormtroopers or not Comey says you know
he bats that down and says stop using
those words and Giuliani says we'll stop
acting like it where do we go Chuck well
again you know I try to be a political
analyst and yet this is kind of like
almost I've used the word antics it's
just this kind of freakish that's going
on between these formerly very
substantial people in our political
system like the former mayor of New York
and the former director of the FBI no I
wouldn't say that Rudy Giuliani chose
the wisest most adequate term when he
called a bunch of FBI agents storm
troopers and furthermore you know they
were there with a search warrant they
didn't barge in like the Gestapo or
something like that that's just
something people across top say the fact
that they felt like not only Cohen rate
but the mana fort for example was very
heavy-handed the way that it was carried
out in the way that things were a
stronger case with respect to mana for
I'll give you that one you know the the
handcuffs and all that stuff or whatever
the the tags were no not great sorry but
you know they they they dotted all their
eyes and crossed all their t's with
respect to Michael Cohen I agree it's
controversial to go into a lawyer's
office but they so far as we know our
following procedure so basically what
Rudy Giuliani is engaged in it's just
you know he's he's working the refs as
Tom said and he's just trying to spend
but to this point today that Cowan was
wiretapped NBC later corrected their
reporting our reporting has been that
there was this pen register where they
log phone calls when they go in when
they go out how long they are you know
Judge Napolitano sat here at the
beginning of the show saying charlie he
doesn't think that they did not listen
he doesn't think they could have
resisted that temptation and they
probably did listen to phone calls and
whatever these are huge constitutional
issues who authorized such a thing your
talk about the president the United
States you talk about its personal
attorney and and I do think that you
know you know maybe the president hasn't
been fully forthcoming about the the
stormy Daniels thing at every step of
the way but you know not being fully
forthcoming to people to the American
people is not a crime it's there's no
that's not a violation and and when you
look at the charges that the president
colluded with Russia to jilt in an
American election those are the those
are the charges that Muller is going
after and then to come around to this
nonsense about the stormy Daniels NDA
payment where it went and who and all
this stuff it's almost like going after
Al Capone for for his income tax evasion
it's this is not this has nothing to do
with the serious crimes that the the
serious charges that were leveled
against the president and it's like it's
like well now you know the prosecutor
she needs he needs some kind of scalp on
his wall so we're gonna come up with
some cocked up the version of some
nonsense and and there's a real have a
real problem with that well I know what
we've seen officially so far no evidence
of collusion as we now await the Muller
investigation although you know one of
the witnesses who is interviewed
yesterday said if you think that's off
the table you're not paying attention